what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation join today by my friend
Aaron Alexander what's your Instagram
handle Aaron finally I can tell you
people I'm back can I cuss can I say
words like that not yet I'm back the
babies too early in the video the real
Aaron Alexander that is my Instagram you
can also find me on Tick Tock at Aaron
alexander64. it's like I carried away
here oh you can put Coy's Tick Tock we
can't [ __ ] my dick talk yes we can't eat
white man
[Laughter]
after one year later of watching Kung Fu
Hustle we have listened to your requests
we're gonna watch challenge soccer
it's a little late it still gets views
that video and I was like I think we
should watch Shaolin Soccer anyway guys
uh leave a like of course full
interaction watch alongs where you sync
up with your own copy for Shaolin Soccer
available for super sexy Rejects at our
patreon page over there cover several
shows we're at the same tier you get the
option for reaction highlights and watch
songs included exclusively let's do this
you excited here I'm more than excited I
am juvial jubilated
I haven't had coffee yet
good we'll get seven o'clock at night
let's not do that to you let's go
talk to him please
that's how I got my shoes ready on Aaron
today
and then I didn't wear them it's black
panther month Greg
[Music]
oh he missed
[Applause]
oh my God
oh my god
[Music]
wow
soccer really is brutal boy
team evil
[Music]
damn Danny's still doing this
oh that's a different guy oh that's the
guy the [ __ ] the tables have turned
uh you really can't watch foreign movies
can
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and what is gay
Tom something
hey man you shouldn't have been a dick
that one day
no way wow
I could do that
that's that's the thing I said I can't
do in the beginning
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
that would be cool
wow you could do so many chores
efficiently if you knew Xiaolin kung fu
[Music]
awesome
hell yeah
what fun cheese I don't have subtitles
to tell me what that says
yes
[Music]
this guy
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's like some Zach King Vine [ __ ]
right there
[Music]
oh and yang
balance
she's got like an acne or eczema
condition
I mean I didn't notice
[Music]
damn she got the eggs rolling are you
making an egg roll joke I am now
[Music]
there's
such a specific style to these movies
[Music]
complimenting you
'll be a shop
oh
yeah
[Laughter]
okay
foreign
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
get it
ready
oh there is Passion being
inspired right now oh man
[Music]
it's great
I don't know what's happening right now
but they are being moved
[Laughter]
only gonna watch Steven Chow movies for
the rest of our lives now
nothing else
there's just nothing else like this
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hahaha
wow
this looks like outtakes
[Music]
hey
[Music]
oh my God
foreign
yeah so I thought
oh yeah
[Music]
this looks genuinely painful that was
mean
[Music]
it's the same can you can kill people on
the soccer field
kick like that she just kicked him
you really gotta
get like a great capture of a tone and
style to get away with this kind of
wacky [ __ ] it's so well done it's so
well done
[Music]
oh he's about to get his revenge
let's get your revenge on something more
philosophical and deep
ER
oh the power
and knock your head clean off
foreign
wow
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
this movie's awesome
just don't think this movie can get more
wacky
please
[Music]
[Laughter]
no
[Laughter]
you will
[Music]
[Laughter]
soon
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh my gosh she could join the soccer
team
good she gotta she gotta get that rhythm
in her
[Music]
whoa feet oh it's gonna be a little
patch that's cute
foreign
[Music]
thumbs up bro
is that homie from the other movie I
think so hey um
[Laughter]
foreign
this is the most relatable guy in the
whole movie right
he's Kung Fu to do it let's get that one
just for me
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh no
foreign
[Laughter]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
gotta get the gang back together gotta
reconnect they all carry that photo
though I do mean something to him
hey lazy Pig cleaned his face
[Music]
foreign
like the shades
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's like Michael Bay shots
this is not how you're gonna play soccer
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
oh lazy Pig
I don't do that don't do that stop it
control yourself
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh God
[Music]
no
oh God
not bad okay
okay self-control not bad
not bad CGI egg okay
that's a real egg here
[Laughter]
[Music]
damn you're getting this yeah I made the
egg larger clearly
it's so cool though I don't care
I mean I don't think he needs to play
with anybody else on the team I think
he's kind of I think he's gonna one man
this
is
what I was thinking yeah
okay
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
that's how you play
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh it's messed up
that is messed up damn
that is not how you play soccer
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
thank you
damn are you a seizure what the hell
[Laughter]
this movie is insane
[Music]
Fair Point
s
[Laughter]
shorts off
[Laughter]
what foreign
[Music]
oh
oh that is actually really cool
oh my God
what a shot that's awesome
I'm gonna be imma be I'm gonna be
[Laughter]
Ironhead yes
that's a real ball
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh damn awesome
that's awesome yeah that's so fun
[Laughter]
[Music]
laughs
oh my God
[Music]
this is incredible
[Music]
[Music]
I can't believe I'm
um
[Laughter]
yeah you're smiling
okay Rocky what's up
[Music]
hmm
[Laughter]
sorry made your hand dirty
oh now he's just like a Bruce Lee outfit
is so funny
[Music]
thank you
[Laughter]
laughs
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh my God
[Music]
he's the feeling
[Music]
this is an inventive ass movie Man
this is really creative yeah
really funny because I think it's
funnier than Kung Fu Hustle yeah
laughs
and it's like really cool
[Music]
that was awesome
stop
[Laughter]
[Music]
hey it's the [ __ ] guy oh yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
God damn that makeup right
Square
[Laughter]
she's joking around
she's behaving so differently she's
drunk what's going on
confidence overnight
I like you better when you were a shy
Meek woman oh is she upset
um
leave her alone
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
Cinema
[Laughter]
[Music]
you're a great friend
[Music]
wait what
I'm gay
[Music]
love that girl
you talk so much about her looks too you
know
I think he definitely gave the wrong
message
why are you being so aggressive dude I
got no time baby I'm a career man now
this is
foreign
oh my God they found their equals
[Music]
that's cool they're running on wires
that's awesome oh yeah
[Music]
no
[Music]
dumbass
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh
[Music]
this movie makes me want to speak
Chinese gibberish but it would just come
across racist right now
laughs
somebody wants me to make something I
wouldn't mean it and I'm making fun of
what I ever made it and I want to talk
like that
it would be sounding racist
[Laughter]
[Music]
she's an emotional Baker
[Music]
tastes like a heartbroken tastes like
her tears
oh I feel so bad for her he was such a
doctor
[Music]
or just embodied Bruce Lee over the
course of this movie
it's so funny
yeah I'm just as confused as you
sponsored by Puma
what are they oh this is his super team
is underwater boys
[Music]
whoa Winter Soldier
[Laughter]
yes
that's so good the winter soccer
you should have taken the money should
have took that money honey
[Music]
[Laughter]
damn
[Music]
damn you kicked like straight into his
hands though
right
goddamn Americans
really are super soldiers where can I
get these drugs
[Laughter]
oh Jesus
foreign
[Laughter]
oh my God this truck's Gotta Wear off
after a while right
oh you can feel that I felt that one
wait
higher
please
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
damn the crowd's barely reacting to this
amazing soccer match
[Music]
don't even aiming for the goal posters
aiming for him right
[Music]
God damn
it is good
yes
[Music]
please guys that's a cool shot
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
what
[Music]
oh no no no
oh
no oh oh drama
Iowa
oh my God
she shaved her head
oh I love this movie
her Skin's all cleared up I saw that
hair no it sounds like you need some new
shampoo and conditioner because all that
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ]
[Laughter]
oh yep she's got the Misty hand she
knows what she's doing oh
[Music]
holy Christ
[Music]
hey
she's one with the ball
she is one with the bun so fast it's
transparent
[Music]
my God twister
take his clothes off
butt naked
[Laughter]
I thought I was just gonna be a shirt
given that there's no field for them to
play on anymore I don't think I know
there was so much property damage right
no kissy kiss kiss this movie's a crock
of [ __ ]
[Laughter]
ah it's to go from the beginning
oh she picked up Kung Fu didn't she
yeah
it worked he inspired I mean you gotta
know he's the soccer player that you
were probably inspired to say Kung Fu
from right now
that's a cool end Nick the whole town
yeah it's part of the whole sound that's
awesome
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
where's that sequel
oh my God I threw real exit Jesus
Jesus
that was cool that was fun that was so
fun
that was like so fun
I had such a blast with that movie that
was a lot funnier than I thought it was
going to be and I had a phenomenal time
watching it yeah would you would you
think Aaron I'm gonna ask you to do the
thing you don't like doing which is
we're not taking a breather we're just
gonna go in there you're gonna start
giving your opinions now man man man
this movie was dog [ __ ]
I have a fake laugh the entire time
nothing is real this is our religion
just for the thumbnail
I had to give Greg some varieties hour
50 minutes of Faking It birth
oh man this movie uh this was cool man
this was it was like a it was like anime
it was it was so heartfelt
it was yeah it was just everything that
I needed right now so it was a long day
and this is this movie just brought joy
to my face
um yeah I thought from beginning to end
it just was
kept topping itself it was really
unexpected uh the cinematography of it
was was very original in the sense that
the the camera work kind of I don't know
they had a lot of really cool shots like
with that with the zooming in on my eyes
and just like how they would play with
soccer I never thought soccer could look
so cool and
it's usually such a boring thing
it's a snog Fest
laughs
oh man you know it's on a real Vibe with
the characters you know what it was for
me it was had this this really good
balance of being really heartfelt also
being really funny yeah I think that it
balanced those two things really well
and it made you care about the
characters while also like making you
buy into the Ridiculousness of the world
that they set up while the events were
unfolding yeah I think at the it was
because you said like from the beginning
you know it just kept hopping itself and
it's so true because
I remember just getting so like I don't
remember exactly when
I think it was the first time he has the
fight with the with the game when he
fights him he's like I'm gonna play
soccer I'm playing soccer because he's
trying not to acknowledge he's actually
in a real fight
and it was getting so ridiculous and I
was like damn really like 25 minutes in
is this gonna like fizz out you know
what I mean like is this ridiculous it's
gonna be like right is this cap yes is
it gonna just get annoying now is it
gonna like how could it possibly stay
like consistent right uh because it was
so big you know it's so early on
and then it did get bigger and bigger
but it got better it just kept getting
better too like it was so enjoyable from
the get-go and
um it it's it's humor feels so sincere
and there's some there's a weird as like
ridiculous and as much of a sketch as it
is there is something that feels like oh
there's it feels like there's a lot of
love infused into what they put together
here because it is very creative and
there are some impressive things with
the camera stuff because yeah first
they're doing some soccer [ __ ] you're
like yeah you can tell it's a fake Ball
but it does such a good job at capturing
the right the right feel that you buy
into it and you don't even like question
the CGI of things anymore and you just
buy into it and it becomes effective
that by the time you get to your final
match you're like dude there's some
stakes in this match right now
it's really enjoyable and Stephen
challenge is so hilarious I like this
more than Kung Fu Hustle I did too and
and I feel like Kung Fu hustles the one
I I could be wrong I I just think
generally Kung Fu Hustle is the one
that's more talked about yeah hardly
yeah I didn't I hadn't seen either of
them before we watched it but that's
yeah my general consensus too that yeah
that's the more popular one but this
one's hilarious and it's so good in the
sense that you know you really Vibe with
all the characters you know even though
some of them are dicks but yeah
but no I think they really endear you to
this team and kind of building off what
you were saying with with you just think
it's gonna
um get stale or get annoying after a
while but I think the thing about it
amping itself up you just it gets you
excited to see like to what level they
can take it to next other elements of
the movie that kind of reminded me of
Space Jam I mixed with like some anime
that I've seen and I was just like I
wouldn't be surprised if the Space Jam
theme started playing right now like
it's better than Space Jam it's a much
better movie
that's a hot take yeah it's a hot take
man you don't want to talk about MJ that
way
yeah no I but I I get the comparison
you're making because it is like a live
action cartoon like there's it's weird
there's some things that like I only saw
Kung Fu Hustle what time I watched you
and that was like a year ago so I don't
really remember the details of what we
said but I feel like there's some points
that you can make that are similar
um I guess I just I genuinely had more
not that I want to make this like a
versus thing between them because I
think the difference is like Kung Fu
Hustle is is a martial arts comedy yeah
and this is it's definitely like also
martial arts comedy but it's also more
of a sports movie yeah where that's more
of a play on like you know uh I I I'm
remembering correctly like gangsters and
Marshall and like Kung Fu characters and
this is a this is like a sports film
yeah and it follows the sports film
model you know it's kind of like the
replacement have you seen The
Replacements with Keanu Reeves no no
okay well I guess that is I can't really
work that it's like a sports comedy but
it's really funny
um and yeah like getting the band back
together to bring something new and
fresh and I did notice like especially
when it got to the point where their
powers are Unleashed
and I was like this is so cool and I'm
excited for them I'm like oh I'm I'm
really I'm more than just finding this
funny like I'm invested in what's going
on yeah and and so I think that just
helps elevate it like they there's a lot
of care that's put into this that I
think is really inventive and even
though there are like the CGI soccer
ball moments and whatever like it's
really not a big deal to me because the
actors themselves are still doing like
crazy martial arts and crazy gymnastics
and acrobatics and wire work and stuff
so it's not like it's all just CGI
there's the people are still involved
doing [ __ ] yeah you know and working
around it and and that stuff still
really shines and yeah these guys are
just all so funny like it's so funny
yeah funny ass movies it's a funny ass
movie and it's not only goofy comedy
it's like it's smart comedy and it's
like it's it's slapstick it's clever
it's situational
it's yeah it just I feel like it just
has all the all the elements checks all
the boxes for making something both
enjoyable and heartfelt but also really
cool I was just like this is straight up
like a live match
and I wish that more movies today would
would do stuff like this because I I
can't think of any other movies that
I've seen in recent history that that
take elements like this and bring it to
movies within like the last five to ten
years and that could actually make it
work like it it takes a real confident
and specific handle on it like this is
something that could easily be a a messy
and annoying but yeah you're right
there's all there's all kinds of comedy
in here even like the dumb comedy is is
the smart dumb comedy were people the
way I hear people I I didn't watch Three
Stooges but the way I hear people talk
about the slapstick of Three Stooges of
how that was actually smart slapstick
um they that's kind of what the
conversation I hear about that is what I
would sort of apply here this is so
that's what I mean there's like things
you would say they would say the same
thing about Kung Fu Hustle with its
slapstick comedy with its Looney Tunes
aspects or whatever but I I still think
what they did here was great because I
was I was really endeared to the
relationship between
um Stephen Chow I forget the characters
Stephen Chow and the girl mui mui sure
mui yeah m-u-i
um have you seen the show Hunter Hunter
I've seen the anime first episode of
Hunter Hunter he's his character other
than when he was becoming like kind of a
dick his character reminds me of the
main character from there gone of
someone who is just like
very ambitious super optimistic always
got a smile on his face ready to go and
and sees the good in people and always
believes in people and he's got that
sort of uh uh what is the word I'm
trying to say I don't know something
like something that means being unfazed
even though he can't get phased but he's
just he's resilient in that in his
Endeavors and I really do love the way
Stephen Chow played this character a lot
and uh they've been rooted for the coach
you know and it's like we don't really
get a focus on you know team evil too
much but the way they
the way they build up the main bad guy
who is just so sleazy it it's like when
they when they say the move at the
beginning of the Moon they're like team
evil you're just like you know exactly
what kind of movie you're in yeah it's
really self-aware and knows exactly the
kind of movie it is and it never shies
away from that and never shies away from
its own Ridiculousness but it's also got
a spirit about it like if they all learn
Kung Fu with it when everyone's doing
Kung Fu like his dream came true like
the whole point was not to
the whole point the whole purpose of
what he wanted to do was not to become a
millionaire or something like that it
was to inspire people to to learn Kung
Fu as a way of life and then like oh
[ __ ] you forget about that until that
moment and you're like that's the whole
purpose it's kind of beautiful yeah the
movie makes you feel good and I like
that that moment where like at the
beginning like they're all down bad
financially you know and then the coach
has the the meeting with his old uh
rival or from the leader of team evil
and he like turns down the money he's
like no we're here for the champion yeah
I was like oh yeah it's me I don't know
this makes you feel good it was a
feel-good fun funny movie and I feel
like that's a a rare combination to
check all three of those boxes yeah
inventive creative great actors everyone
was everyone was so good
is and you know like there is a there's
a specific type of timing I feel it's
it's cool to me there's something cool
about how
I don't know because you gotta because
we have to read the subtitles yeah right
but it but some of the dialogue and the
delivery was it still takes a specific
kind of delivery it's not just because
we're reading the subtitles and the
subtitles funny it's there is a specific
type of delivery so I do feel like it's
cool that even though it's in a
different language it could still be it
still have hilarious like scenes of just
dialogue yeah I think that's a a
testament to to the writing and how he
directed the movie because you know
humor laughter as a is something that is
generally human but not all humor from
different regions translate to different
countries I feel like this movie was so
well made because we don't speak Chinese
we don't speak pattern but you know as
we were watching it we were dying
laughing because it's still hilarious
universally yeah it's a it's a great
film I thought it was true I thought it
was great it's awesome one of the best
things I've seen this year like I've
watched a lot of movies this year oh oh
man this is one of the best movies I've
seen this year I was I was really uh I
was touched by it I thought it was an
amazing ass film and uh
God the only Stephen chamber was I hear
about our Kung Fu Hustle and
and Shaolin Soccer I was just like I
want to watch all those movies yeah what
else has he done recently has he done
anything oh man he's gotten older people
aged since 2004. wow his Skin's still
great though Skin's very Asian man you
know how they are right you just barely
say that and it's still a [ __ ] common
if it wasn't
it's a great thing to say a positive
thing to say
[Laughter]
uh as director as director oh he did
direct Shaolin Soccer God damn he
directed Shaolin Soccer
wow let it and directed it
I'm trying to see isn't it towards the
top of the movie actor oh he's not
really doesn't really active since 2008
really what the hell Stephen what is he
directed though
so Kung Fu Hustle I don't ever not heard
of any of the other movies I've ever
heard of these other films now the new
king of comedy what what I've never
heard of them I was a cool
poster though the mermaid damn it was
one mermaids one of his highest grossing
films of all I never heard of this movie
what is another comedy we gotta watch
all the Stephen Chow movies yep
just go down a whole list how many
being from Beijing with love okay he's
so funny you could also tell he's like
he's probably just like an insane hard
worker oh yeah to be like a talented
martial artist and director and actor
like did he write the movie too
I I wonder
I don't think so
written because yeah oh wow damn triple
threat
that's awesome
this man can't be stops
oh apparently in like 2008 yeah
[Laughter]
he's still alive right yeah
60. damn he's 60.
dude does not look 60. wow anyway uh
I I love this movie made soccer cool and
then uh it's it's also
super inventive Super Creative it's very
creative stuff the best soccer thing I
ever seen I haven't seen Ted lasso so
don't get mad at me
it's got such an understanding of the
one I've ever seen Taylor it's got such
an understanding of of the world I think
that's I think if someone wants to watch
it be like yeah it's just so random and
I'm like I don't know I mean it feels
like it's all stemming from the crazy
imagination of of this guy because even
when he's like on the field and he's
like going through the the war trenches
yeah and then you see that he just has a
stick and stuff I'm like okay so as part
of this kind of like the crazy
imagination that he has you know like
there's a lot of this actually
physically happening where some of this
just the way he sees it right and you
know is it his perspective perspective
yeah there's no wonder it's like a wise
crack video to do about this
deep provoking break down the lane
it was all in his mind
the philosophy yeah it is the way to do
it all right guys thanks for being here
thanks for being here I'm glad we could
both enjoy this movie that was a fun ass
film
um sorry it took us a year to watch it
worth it game at the right time see you
guys soon
[Music]